thank you all so much for coming to see
my talk I really appreciate you showing
up and being interested and thanks for
any strange loop organizers who may be
in the room for hosting the talk it's a
real pleasure to be able to come here
I've been wanting to come to Strange
Loop for a long time at this talk today
I'd like to give you just a little taste
of what dependent types may have to
offer I'm not going to teach you sort of
the deep mathematical background or go
into how you can use them at work but I
hope to at least convey just a little a
little piece of the the joy and beauty
that I think dependent types have my
name is David I work in sunny Portland
Oregon at a company called Galois and
but for the last couple of years I lived
in Bloomington Indiana where I was a
postdoc at Indiana University and dan
Friedman my co-author who's sitting
there in the third row and I put this
book together through a couple of years
of hard work so I hope you like it
so what are dependent types why why
might you think they're kind of fun well
maybe you've been reading a blog post
about how fun it is to write code in a
dress which is a dependently type
language that looks a lot like Haskell
except it uses one colon to put a type
on a thing
and two colons to make a list or you may
have been working with Agda which is
addresses older cousin which is really a
wonderful system to work with or you may
have looked on as people end up making
an entire C compiler and proving that it
doesn't have any bugs at all using a
system called [ __ ] which has also been
used for tons of other really
large-scale impressive projects the the
fact that the French government has
funded the development of [ __ ] for such
a long time is a wonderful gift to
humanity and we should all be grateful
to them or you may have been looking at
big mainstream languages like Scala and
Haskell and and and seeing that that
more and more patterns that people are
using on a daily basis are inspired by
dependently type programming and and and
thinking what what is what are these
dependent types but like most great
things in computer science dependent
type theory didn't start in the 90s long
ago in the 90s it didn't start in the
2000 it started around the last turn of
the century not the most recent one when
when I was in high school but the one
before my birth and there was a
controversy in the philosophy of
mathematics saying like well what what
what are we doing when we do mathematics
and the the traditional account going
back to the ancient Greeks to Plato has
been that the world is some sort of poor
reflection of the true existing objects
of mathematical reality you know the the
circle on the top of my coffee cup is
sort of like a bad version of the
ultimate circle and and people started
thinking well there's there's some
problems with this approach and the
official thing that we have which was
sort of famously advocated by David
Hilbert back then was this idea that
mathematics is actually ultimately
meaningless
we're not accessing the true high
reality of things in fact we're just
we're just playing games meaningless
games and we're playing those
meaningless games with meaningless
symbols according to arbitrary rules and
just so happens that we like some of
those arbitrary rules better than others
and you know eventually hopefully we'll
have machines that can play those games
bed
than we can another approach that was
pioneered by a dutch mathematician
Brauer who is not as well-known as David
Hilbert but has done a lot of wonderful
things is this idea that actually
mathematical objects aren't meaningless
but they also don't sort of exist prior
to and above and beyond the world that
we actually live in and inhabit on a
daily basis instead they exist in the
minds of people doing mathematics
they're fundamentally about ideas about
our own experience of these mental
constructions and sort of coming out of
that philosophical tradition as well as
some later European philosophical
traditions the Swedish philosopher Pere
Martin they've put together his
intuitionistic type theory starting in
the 1970s also prior to my own birth and
intuitionistic type theory took some of
what brow verse students had done
putting intuitionistic logic yeah
Brauer series intuition ISM is what it
was called and taking a sort of a form
of logical reasoning that was
appropriate for this idea of mental
constructions and building it up so that
it was a much bigger theory you've sort
of big enough that we can do all the
math that we want and Martin the pair
Martin they've put out a few different
versions of his intuitionistic type
theory and meanwhile ta Hong Kong and
Hugh a they were working on the calculus
of constructions which was another
approach to doing this and it turns out
that Martin lives type theory and the
calculus of constructions look at awful
lot like functional programming
languages and then meanwhile in the
British Isles shall we put together a
core type theory that was sort of a
version of calculus of constructions
with inductive types and a lot of
extensions used in the Lego system and
then the calculus of constructions
itself as being developed for the Kok
system which we mentioned earlier that
inherited a lot of the features that
were eventually developed in the in the
Swedish context and we ended up with a
lot of convergent evolution of these
languages ending up with the actual
systems that had that B could sit down
and use and type things in so we have
coq still today an early I'll turn
approach was epigram an epigram inspired
a system agda which was based on earlier
swedish systems and idris was inspired
by epigram and Agda a lot of previous
epigram people worked on address and and
today we have these things in languages
that we can download and run and
reasonably use to write real programs
you can write pack that in them as idris
as creator edwin ready likes to say that
pacman completeness is more important
than turing completeness but it's one
thing to be able to use something on
your computer it's it's something else
to to get insight into the inner
workings of it to see how it works and
that knowledge has been pretty hard to
acquire traditionally you have to pretty
much know somebody who's able to point
you to the right papers and help you
interpret them and say oh that thing
they're talking about there where do we
go for the information to understand the
context and the ideas and sort of build
up the intuitive understanding that
allows you to read computer science
papers as interesting literature rather
than as a chore that you have to
struggle through and that that just
takes a lot of time and so a mutual
friend adam folker introduced dan and i
and said well hey Dan's writing these
series of books like the little schemer
that teach deep ideas without assuming
that you're a mathematician maybe the
two of you could work together on one
for dependent types and yup that sounds
great and and we just finished it it
came out last week it's called the
little piper
oh thanks
and the the response has been a little
overwhelming and I'm very happy about
that thank you and so I for the little
Piper we we didn't feel that we could
use an existing dependently typed
programming language because it turns
out that in order to make these things
practical for getting real work done you
automate away a lot of the things that
are difficult to do but sometimes
confronting difficulty and overcoming it
is an educational experience it teaches
you how to work with a thing so we
wanted to put together a language that
we could use to demonstrate the
fundamental principles of dependent type
theory without anything being automated
away but where we could still fit it in
the narrow two column format of a little
book and we didn't find one that suited
our needs so we made our own and it's
called pi so i'd like to give you a
little demonstration of how pi works and
this is p IE you know they kind of eat
so I'm gonna write a program in PI and
that program is 5
I like the number 5 so looking at the
screen here we can see that I typed ha I
type 5 up top and PI responded saying
that's the NAT 5 and it's also got a
little green check mark down to the
corner which means your program is a-ok
I could also write 23 and it responds 23
programs that evaluate to themselves are
not the most fun of programs we will get
to some more functional programs later
but in the meantime let's look at a few
more simple programs sometimes I want to
do things other than numbers I like food
so one kind of food that I like is
apples so I can type apples with a quote
mark and pie response apples yep but
note that it's also got another thing
after the word of the so before we had
van at 5 but now we have the Adam apples
so the thing between the and the and the
result of the program is what we call a
type and a type describes a program it
tells you a lot about what that program
is going to do and in the case of NAT it
means it's going to give you back a
natural number so some of the natural
numbers are things like 0
add one of 0 add one of add 1 of 0 and
so forth negative numbers are unnatural
we can also write the descriptions
ourselves so I can say the NAT 23 I can
say the Adam Pizza I can even say the
Adam Opel because I like a bull it's
very delicious bread if you ever go to
Denmark get some but I have other
descriptions than just NAT and Adam
there's some descriptions that combine
other descriptions so I can say the pair
NAT Adam and we make pairs with our good
old friend cons so we can say cons 23
and I didn't come up with a list of food
what's your favorite food somebody tell
me
ice cream ice bread what that's that's
not food so so then we get back the pair
NAT Adam cons 23 ice cream pretty tasty
23 ice creams might get a stomachache
actually how about we just say two ice
creams
that's suitably decadent but if I were
to say cons ice cream - then I get back
instead of my friendly green checkmark I
get an angry red X and I find out that
PI expected based on the description
that I gave it a NAT but instead I gave
it an Adam this is the dreaded type
error and for a very fun program I can
write a function so I can say the arrow
NAT NAT and then we use our old friend
lambda and let's say we just want to
turn the same net and then we find out
that lambda K K is a function where when
we give it in that it'll give us back a
NAT that's what this arrow means a lot
of languages put the arrow in the middle
but I like it at the beginning I can
also write lambda k plus K K and I can
write lambda N and plus N n I can even
use the letter J if I want
it turns out that changing the name of a
bound variable doesn't affect the
meaning of a program thankfully so
that's pretty cool
types tell us a lot about our programs
throughout this I'm gonna be showing
some of the chapter art both to
demonstrate to you that we're flying
through this book and also because I
really love the artwork that Dewayne
Bibby made for our book I'm super happy
about it here we see the the elephant
from the little schemer handing a basket
of parentheses to this to this bear
who's about to learn type theory so not
only do types describe programs types
also tell us which of the program's they
describe are the same as each other and
it turns out that four is the same gnat
as four and here I'm asking PI would you
please check for me that four is in fact
the same night as four and it replies
with the green checkmark indeed four is
the same mat as four if I were to ask
whether four is the same that as five
well it's not four and five are not the
same that but sameness is not entirely
trivial for instance I can also say
check whether two plus two and four are
the same gnat and I can check whether
one plus three and four are the same
gnat and indeed they are
this means that sameness respects
computation that's sort of one of the
key insights that pan Watson live had
was giving us a framework in which we
could make a language that automatically
respects computation and this works for
all the types not just the types like
gnat and pair where you can imagine
behind the scenes there's sort of a
layout in memory that can be checked by
of values and having bit forbid identity
or some sort of recursive function that
reverses them and checks them in fact we
can do we can check whether two
functions are the same so we can see for
example that lambda K K is the same
arrow gnat gnat as lambda J
J so these don't compile to the same
thing or maybe they do depends on the
compiler but sameness is about the
meaning of the program much more than
it's about the eventual result of
compiling it and checking some values in
memory and we can even see here is that
what if we let's say we add 0 here to
decay so it turns out that lambda K + 0
K and lambda J J are the same function
from that - net I could also say +1 here
they're not the same and add one here
and once I balance my parentheses
they're the same again so sameness
respects computation even inside of a
lambda that's pretty neat I think so so
I've shown you a lot of ways to build
things up but not a lot of ways to use
the things that have been built so we're
not only interested in programs that put
together a number or make a function
we're also interested in programs that
do recursion over a number to see to do
different things depending on which
number we got and we're interested in
programs that apply functions that call
them to find out what their value is
when provided with an argument we call
this eliminating those things it sound
it sounds very stressful actually like
I'm gonna eliminate those functions but
but it can be friendly and here we see
some natural numbers being eliminated
from this Bears cave so I've been acting
so far as though plus is something that
we completely understand but plus isn't
a built in in pi we have to build it
ourselves using simpler tools so when I
say claim that means I'm about to define
a thing called plus and it's going to be
described by the type arrow NAT NAT NAT
which is to say we're gonna give it two
Nats and it'll give us back a net so
having claimed plus I'd better define it
note that pi is not in credit not
entirely convinced yet it's got this
this question mark down here
I don't know that plus looks suspicious
we'd better define it we define + and
well that's how we're gonna define +
well pi looks kind of like scheme
it's not scheme but it looks kind of
like scheme let's let's try writing it
in scheme so we could say well the first
thing we'll do is we'll check whether oh
we're gonna say lamda first lambda JK
and then we're gonna check well is is J
0 and if J is indeed 0 then we're going
to return K because 0 plus K is K and if
J is something other than 0 then our
answer is going to be the result of
adding 1 to the result of adding 1 minus
J so J minus 1 if we write sub 1 of J to
K we've got a problem
hi doesn't have if PI doesn't even have
boolean z' it turns out that you can
build boolean's out of simpler tools so
so what are we gonna do here well each
each type not only does it come with
constructors which allow you to build
the values of those types you've seen
some constructors already like 0 and add
one like lambda like every atom as a
constructor but we also have these
eliminators that let us use things made
out of that type to make things in any
old type so here we can use an
Eliminator called which nab because
that's what we're doing right we're
checking which net we've got have we got
0 or have we got add 1 of something else
and if we've got 0 well we're gonna
check that on J and if we've got 0 we
want to return K just as before the
second argument to which net should be a
function so I'm gonna control K here and
say lambda and this function you know if
we've got add one of if J is add 1 of
something then that's something is the
result of J minus 1 so I'm just gonna
call this variable J minus 1 we're
allowed to have hyphens and variable
names here and then the result will be
at one of + J minus 1 okay and we're
almost there
except we're not Oh No
so what we've tried to do is we've tried
to define plus using plus but it turns
out that in pi when you're defining
things recursion is just not an option
hey Dan why is recursion not an option
in pi yeah but but but why isn't it an
option but but why isn't recursion an
option so it turns out that when you
want to use your programming language as
the logic as a source of truth then
justifying things by themselves is a
little bit problematic and indeed
recursion is not an option in pi so
instead we rather than defining things
recursively where they refer to
themselves in their own right hand side
in their own meaning instead each type
that has a recursive structure like the
natural numbers provides an Eliminator
that exposes the structure of those
values in such a way that you always
make progress down to the base one so we
have an Eliminator now called
rec nat rec nat is very much like which
nat except that this function here takes
one more argument which is the result of
the recursion on j minus 1 so here we're
gonna call that sum so far and now with
the sum so far is plus J minus 1 and K
so I can say sum so far and I get that
green checkmark and just to see that it
works because even if you're gonna prove
something is right you should probably
test that it's right first to save
yourself hours of pain we want to say
plus 3/5 and we get the nat eight back
so this thing works and because we
didn't use J minus one ever I can just
go ahead and get rid of that and then
use a slightly simpler Eliminator called
Internet which simply doesn't pass the
one smaller net and now we have the
definition of + from our book we've read
a few chapters now another thing I might
want to do is to double a number let's
walk through that process one more time
so I can say define double and then
it'll be lambda
and we'll call it this time for no
apparent reason
and say wreck NAT N and what is double
to zero zero I hear from the audience
great it's a double of zero is zero and
how do we double a number that is one
smaller than n we'll call it lambda n
minus one and so far well we put two
ones on top of it so we can say plus two
so far and then we get back double so we
can say double of three and we get back
but it's been at six just as expected so
types so far have been describing things
that are like the programs we know and
love from most of our other programming
languages but it turns out that types
can describe much more than just numbers
and atoms and pairs and functions types
can also describe evidence which is to
say evidence for some statement in this
case we're having it the claim that two
plus two is four I hope you agree if you
don't I'm going to prove it to you so
evidence that two plus two is four well
let's think two plus two and four those
are the same net we saw that earlier so
we can see define two plus two is four I
should get autocomplete in my slides and
that's going to be same for and what
we're saying is that two plus two is
equal to 4 because 2 plus 2 is the same
as four and four is the same as four I
could also say give evidence that
they're equal by saying plus 1 3 here
and now I'm saying that the evidence
that two plus two equals four is the
fact that two plus two is the same as
one plus three and the fact that four is
the same as one plus three I could even
write plus three one here and it still
works
so that's one kind of statement but
things are equal but actually we have
lots of ways of making statements and we
have ways of putting other statements
together from smaller statements and so
we should think what is the evidence of
those and it turns out that the evidence
of those things is already things we've
seen so if if we have two statements a
and B and we want evidence for the
combined statement a and B well that's a
pair and the car is evidence for a and
the cooter is evidence for B or for
those who are used to other languages
the first thing in the pair is evidence
for a and the second thing in the pair
is evidence for B and a or B well
there's two ways that we could evidence
for a or B we could have well we could
have evidence for a or we could have
evidence for B and pi includes a type
called either which captures this
situation what about evidence that a
implies B hmm so so what I want to know
is that whenever a is the case B will
also be the case and the way I can
capture that is to actually write a
function and this function should be
able to take any old arbitrary evidence
for a you know like maybe there's
multiple ways to get evidence for a for
example maybe a isn't or so it could be
a left of one thing or right of another
thing but whatever it is we should be
able to take any evidence for a and
given that produce new evidence for B
that's the function that's a program and
then as we've seen if we want to see
that x and y are equal according to the
type a well when they're the same a then
we get to use that constructor same that
we saw before what about a false
statement what counts as evidence for a
false statement nothing whatsoever if we
had evidence for a false statement we'd
be in trouble
another way we can make statements is by
talking about particular programs or
particular values particular individuals
so what this type Sigma says is that
there exists some atom and we're going
to call it fruit and it satisfies a
property namely that whatever fruit it
was it's equal to orange so I can say it
turns out that Sigma is actually a
fancier version of pear so I can say
define orange exists and then it's going
to be cons and I want to pick some fruit
Apple because I like apples and then we
will say same Apple because we want to
show that it's equal and it turns out
that it's actually not equal to orange
what happened was the first thing in the
pear the car let that's Apple but the
second thing here it was supposed to
have the type that the that whatever
fruit in other words Apple is that it's
equal to orange but apples aren't
oranges so instead we should say cons
orange and same orange and then we get
our green check mark in other words
Sigma is the type of what we call
dependent pears the type of the second
thing in the pear is allowed to refer to
the value in the the first thing in the
pear by name and it and actually pear
the type we saw earlier is an
abbreviation for Sigma where that name
just isn't used so if we want to define
what it means for a natural number to be
even then we get to write a function
because we want to work for any old
natural number so even is going to be a
function that takes an at and then gives
us back something called a u u is a type
that describes many other types it
doesn't describe itself because that
would make various things go wrong in
the logic but it does describe types
like atom and pair atom gnats and gnats
and functions and also Sigma's and so
even is going to be something
where we give it an at and it gives us
back the type that describes evidence
for that particular nap that we just
gave it to be even so you know it's got
a lambda and note that I wrote to do
here so in PI sometimes it's nice to not
have to write a whole program at once so
we can sprinkle it with two dews and get
back to them later and we'll just have
that little yellow question mark until
we're ready so what does it mean for a
number to be even well it it means that
we can cut it in half evenly so in other
words it means that there exists some
other number so Sigma and we're going to
call that other number half it's going
to be an at and what property does that
number have well it turns out equal nat
n and then double half yeah because if
you double half of something you should
get it back and if n were an odd number
then we wouldn't be able to do that we
wouldn't be able to cut it into
something we're doubling it would get it
back so if I want to see what is even of
6 then we see it's this u this element
of the universe which is what u is an
abbreviation for Sigma half in that such
that NAT equals two and then we see the
definition that we ended up writing for
double getting unfolded a little bit
here yeah so this this is a now we're on
chapter 12 by the way the book the book
proceeds at a pace which I think helps
keep you help you keep up with it is
zero an even number well I've heard some
controversy on that fact but given the
way we've defined even this it is we
could we can prove it so we need to find
evidence that zero is even because even
zero well that if we think about what
does even mean well that means Sigma
half so we got to figure out what half
of zero is and half of zero is a number
we're doubling it gives you back zero
yeah it's zero good job awesome
so it's going to be cons zero and then
same zero is the evidence that double
zero equals zero because double zero is
the same net as zero so it all works out
so zero is indeed even we've we've
solved the mystery and if we want to get
evidence of oddness well that's going to
be let's see
so when we cut it in half there's one
left over so we'll say Sigma half nat
equal net and and now we want to say add
one of double but wait half is the wrong
name this isn't half it's almost half so
we call it half and so evidence of
oddness says that we've got this half
half which is almost half is almost half
in my dialect of English we pronounced
them the same which is kind of
unfortunate but yeah and so if we wanted
evidence that one is odd we could say
the odd one cons zero same one and it
works out and now we're to chapter 13 so
one thing I might want to do is I want
to I might want to talk not only about a
thing that exists that has some property
but we may also want to say that
everything has some property other words
we talked about there exists and now we
want to talk about for all and just as
there exists ended up being a version of
pair with more information for all ends
up being a version of arrow with more
information so we can say pi and in that
that is a type that describes functions
that are going to take an argument which
is an at but then we're going to name
that argument and then we can use the
argument itself in the rest of the type
so what this type describes is functions
where we give them some NAT that we call
N and then we give them further more
evidence that whatever and it was we
gave it is even and it'll give us back
evidence that add one of that n is odd
and so I've written part of this already
note that this lambda looks like it
takes two arguments
that's because [ __ ] is all of its
functions just like Haskell in other
words if I write a if I write what looks
like a function with two arguments it's
actually two nested functions each of
which take one argument every function
in pi actually takes one argument and so
so I've got n and I've got evidence that
n is even and I need to make evidence
that n plus 1 is odd so if n is even
well let's see so 0 was even half of
half of 0 was 0 and 1 was odd and almost
half of 1 was still 0 so when we go up a
number from an even to an odd then the
half of the even number is almost half
of the odd number so we can take the car
which is to say the first thing the
number have of the even number from the
evidence that n is even and then the
evidence that doubling that and then
adding 1 is equal to our current add 1
of n well we get that by well we know
that we know that doubling car of n is
even gives us n and so we just need to
add 1 to both sides of that equation and
doing something to both sides of an
equation should certainly be ok because
if two things are the same then nothing
can distinguish between them so we can
use an operator called Kong and so Kong
we say could err n is e and what are we
going to do to both sides of the
equation add 1 and this works out so now
we've proven that one greater than any
even number is an odd number and you can
do the same thing to prove that one
greater than an odd number is even I
don't want to bore you oh so now this
this this leads us to be able to pose a
question is every number either even or
odd
oh I claim that it is and the way we're
gonna do that the way we're gonna figure
that out
and this either by the way is the type
that we talked about earlier for
evidence
of Anor using a version of wreck net
called Internet which allows the
recursion to talk about the actual value
being recurred upon right now in other
words we have one more argument which is
this first to do and we get to use this
to do to explain the relationship
between the N we're looking at and the
type of the entire recursion in this
case it's lambda K either even K odd K
and now our two dues say well in this
case right this is the base case of our
recursion so when n is zero then we need
either evidence that add that zero is
even or evidence that zero is odd and we
know how to do that with left which lets
us take the left side of it either and
it's going to be zero is even which we
already found earlier and for the case
of the of the step function the thing
that takes the result of the recursion
on n and gives us back the recursion on
add 1 of n well for that we're gonna
write a helper
so this helper here is called step of
even or odd and it takes some n minus 1
some almost almost the end we're looking
at and evidence as to whether n is even
and -1 is even or n minus 1 is odd and
gives us back evidence that add one of n
minus one is even or that add one of n
minus one is odd and so if we want to
write that function for that we use
something called IND either so we're
gonna take our n minus one we're gonna
take evidence that n minus 1 is either
even or odd then we're going to take
that and produce evidence that well
either one graders even or one graders
odd and the way we do that is by cases
if if it were left then we know that n
minus 1 is even and we know that if n
minus 1 is even then add one of n minus
1 is odd so we put the right constructor
around it
and then use this add one even-odd in
order to transform the evidence that ad
minus one was even into evidence that
add one of n minus one is odd
likewise if n minus one was odd then we
know the add one of n minus one will be
even so we can use this helper add one
odd-even to transform evidence the n
minus one was odd into evidence that add
one of n minus one now is even and
putting all the pieces together we have
our green checkmark we've proven that
every number is either even or odd well
we've done a little more than just
proving that every number is even or odd
right we we were walking through this
thinking okay so what does it mean like
for all there exists or and talking
about talking about our program in in
sort of logical language that's not
where we started out way back at the
beginning of this talk I was talking
about pi as a programming language and
it turns out that we've just written a
program so I can say even or odd of 0
and scrolling past of the definition of
what it means for things to be even and
odd we see left and then that very
evidence we wrote earlier so we got a
program where we give it zero and it
gives us back evidence first off it
gives us back the fact that that zero is
even and evidence of that evenness
namely half of zero if I say even or odd
of 100 then we get back that well yeah
it's even and half of it is 50 what if I
say 113 well then we find out that right
right it's odd and almost half of 113 is
56 in other words the proof that every
number is even or odd is something that
determines the parity and figures out
how to cut it in half I think that's
pretty neat this this is I love this
stuff so thank you so much for coming to
this talk and for listening I really
appreciate it if you want to read the
book if you have any questions you can
get ahold of Dan or I
I have twitter we both have email and if
you're interested in learning more about
type theory the the little fibers out
and I would it would be great if you
wanted to read it
libraries are wonderful you don't have
to buy it thanks so much
[Applause]